[Musique]
étrangère
mélange parfait d'une attitude nord-américaine
à l'enthousiasme et au
bruit vraiment et de l'influence française
parce que la France pour Pink Floyd est une
chose très spéciale,
nous avons eu le soutien du public français à
une époque où dans le reste de l'Europe, ils
n'étaient pas vraiment particulièrement intéressés
mais les Français l'ont absolument compris et je
pense que cela a influencé l'Amérique du Nord,
mettons les applications de shopping en feuilles ne sont pas de la
personnalité, je veux dire les
sections Les
spectateurs et
bien je pense que pour le début pour les premiers
concerts, je ne peux tout simplement pas vraiment m'en souvenir
beaucoup à leur sujet, je veux dire qu'ils l'ont fait
il y a environ 50 ans et je pense que je
devrais l'inventer pour me souvenir de
ces moments spéciaux.
être capable de cracher à 20 mètres
serait même Beyond Roger et c'est donc
un peu apocryphe mais je pense que l'
important c'est que ce n'est pas
spécifique à Montréal c'est en fait à propos de
la di  sconnecter entre
le groupe et et euh et un audio d'
un public énorme parce que nous penserions
apprendre à faire face à des publics de la
taille qui n'envisageraient jamais
technique et pas
une technique exactement mais un style que
les batteurs anglais ont de
tirer sur le timing alors que les
Américains ont tendance à être soit dessus, soit
presque légèrement en avance et je
suppose que si c'est le cas, alors mes
influences étaient tous ces grands batteurs
du  fin des années 60 début des années 70 je veux dire que je suis
ici maintenant parce que j'ai vu Ginger Baker
jouer avec de la crème et j'ai pensé que c'est
ce que j'aimerais faire mais aussi quelqu'un
comme Mitch Mitchell le batteur de Jimi
Hendrix
[Musique]
ton flux en boucle ton flux épique
programmer des médicaments
Dark Side of the Moon J'aimerais que vous soyez
ici au mur,
je pense que d'un point de vue de la drogue,
c'était vraiment l'influence de Sid et
ensuite
ce que nous avons, je pense
y  eah je pense que ce que nous avons vraiment apprécié,
c'est euh les aspects techniques de faire un
bon disque et vous ne faites pas ça avec
des drogues psychédéliques, vous le faites en
améliorant le
fonctionnement de la machine et euh je veux dire je
pense que
le côté particulièrement sombre c'est un très
travail musical technique vraiment il n'y a
rien à voir avec le
psychédélisme  quoi que ce soit que
nous n'ayons jamais traversé Darkseid ou le
mur ou quoi que ce soit et bien que oui, je
ne pourrais pas le faire directement,
mais je pense que vous devez simplement y aller c'est
comme ça
[Musique]